[Musique]
alors nous sommes sur le site de la base
de canoë kayak de mulhouse riedisheim
comme vous pouvez le voir nous avons la
chance d'avoir une nouvelle base depuis
janvier 2018
cet équipement nous permet d'accueillir
des personnes handicapées
le club a fait l'achat
d'un ponton permettant aussi
d'accueillir des personnes à mobilité
réduite
alors dans un premier temps pour
accueillir ces personnes
il nous faudra acquérir du nouveau
matériel adapté à ces personnes là donc
pour lancer l'activité
nous avons commencé
par l'accueil de personnes atteintes
d'un handicap sensoriel donc ce soir
nous avons un groupe de personnes
malentendantes est tout simplement aussi
voilà pourquoi ces personnes tout
simplement parce que le matériel que
nous avons leur permet de pratiquer
comme des personnes valides dans un but
de de continuer à développer cette
activité
nous organisons très prochainement une
porte ouverte dédiée aux personnes
avec un handicap donc pour cela nous
allons dans un premier temps travailler
que les associations spécialisées et
donc cette journée portes ouvertes
permettra à toutes ces associations de
venir se renseigner sur place et même à
des personnes déjà atteintes d'un
handicap
de venir se renseigner et voir comment
on va pouvoir mettre en place une
animation avec eux c'est le but aussi
c'est à un moment ou un autre c'est
d'accueillir ces personnes et d'avoir la
mixité entre les personnes handicapées
et les personnes
les personnes valides voilà donc à un
moment ou un autre il faut que ces deux
percées 2 ces deux publics puissent se
côtoyer et que du coup l'handicap
disparaisse et que ces personnes fassent
partie intégrante de notre association
[Musique]